Underlying cycle twenties let's think
about you referred to the opioid crisis,
for example.
It's the cause.
I think even a lot of really good people
are profoundly misunderstanding what's
happening with the opioid crisis.
Where is the opiod crisis happening
right into a lot of the epicenters of it,
places like Monadnock in New Hampshire.
Why is,
why are things so disastrous there?
Why is there much higher opioid addiction
in West Virginia than on the Faculty
of Harvard?
Right?
People in the Faculty of Harvard have
much better access to opioids, right?
Everyone there has good health insurance.
They have much better access.
What's going on that that
some amazing economists,
Angus Deaton and Ann Case did a massive
study of this and they said that we need
to understand the opioid deaths mainly
is what they call deaths of despair,
right? It's not a coincidence that the
places were opioid addiction is highest,
are also the places where suicide
not with opioids is highest.
We're antidepressant prescriptions
or highest, there's a whole,
these things are clustering
together for a reason, right,
and you don't have to spend much time
in those places to see people through.
No fault of their own.
Have I liked the rats in that first cage
right there had been deprived of the
things that make life meaningful.
It doesn't mean chemical hooks don't
play some role. They do play a role.
But I've been to the places that have
solved this and it wasn't by thinking
primarily about that. So just talk
about the reality, chemical hooks,
if that's the right thing.
It's very important to understand
in relation to opioids.
So it's a very strong agreement among
scientists that the most powerful chemical
hook we know is nicotine,
right?
You smoked cigarettes like my mother
smokes seventies cigarettes a day.
He smoked cigarettes. The thing you feel
a physical craving for when you stop,
which my mother would never do, is, um, is
nicotine, right? That's the chemical hook.
Um, and so in the late eighties,
when nicotine patches were invented,
there's this huge wave of optimism
among scientists because they're like,
I write cigarette smoking is an
addiction to the chemical hook. Nicotine.
Now we can give people all the chemical
hook they're addicted to without any of
this shitty cancer causing smoke. People
are gonna Start Smoking, right? Um,
so nicotine patches are introduced in
the US surgeon general's report a couple
of days later,
fines,
highly motivated people
using nicotine patches. Um,
17% of them will stop smoking right now.
It's important to say that is not nothing,
right?
That means if you meet the Chemical
Hook for people who are addicted to
cigarettes, 17% of them will stop
entirely. That's a big deal, right?
That's saved a huge
number of people's lives.
But obviously 17% is not
100% that leaves 83%.
The got to be explained
by the other things.
And that's really the factors that I
talked about in, in Las connections.
So I mean there's a whole range of them,
but you know, if you are acutely lonely,
we are the loneliest society
there's ever been, right?
You are much more likely to be vulnerable
to despair, depression, addiction.
If you are controlled
or humiliated at work,
which most people now are to some degree,
you're much more
vulnerable to these things.
There's a whole range of go through nine
of these, these factors in the book.
But to me, the most important thing in
thinking about the opioid crisis, and I'm,
I find it really frustrating that this is
never discussed in the American debate,
is I've been to the place that solves
an opioid crisis that had a disastrous
opioid crisis and ended it, right? And
they did something that's very different.
So Americans are being urged to do
so I'm a Swiss citizen because my dad's
from there. So I Switzerland. Well,
and by the time you get to the year 2000,
Switzerland is having like an
opioid nightmare, right? Um,
people can look up videos from the time,
but you know,
people like Swiss people are obsessed
with order is not a coincidence.
They invented clocks that all that
shit. Right? Like in their public parks,
people like injecting in the neck
like nightmare scenes, right?
That'd be bad anywhere. But to Swiss
people, this is like the worst nightmare,
right? And they try all sorts of
things. They tried the American way,
arresting people,
punishing people,
shaming people and it just
keeps getting worse and worse.
And then one day they get this incredible
woman called Ruth Dreifuss who I got
to know later who becomes a minister
of health and then the president,
the first ever female
president of Switzerland. Um,
and she explains to people,
I think the solution is to
legalize heroin. And she said,
I know that sounds really shocking cause
when you hear the word legalization,
what you picture is anarchy and chaos.
She said,
what we have now is anarchy and chaos,
right?
We have unknown criminals selling unknown
chemicals to unknown drug users all in
the dark or filled with violence,
disease and chaos legalization.
She explained as the way we restore
order to this madness, right?
So the way it works isn't,
uh,
I spent a lot of time in
these places and obviously no,
or maybe there's some really
hardcore libertarians,
but almost no one believes
we should legalize heroin
the way alcohol or cannabis
illegal, right? No one thinks there
should be a heroine, Ireland's CBS.
That's not the plan.
Right.
What do you mean Switzerland
is if you had a heroin problem,
you were assigned to a clinic. I went,
spent a lot of time in the one in Geneva,
the former president,
Ruth dreifuss lives opposite this clinic.
I think that tells you
something, um, lives across
the street, across the street.
What, what, what? It's the way
it works is she should move well,
but if you see the clinic
that day, why? Right?
So the way it works is you have to go
to the clinic at seven o'clock in the
morning because Swiss people believe
in doing things really fucking early.
It's constant disagree. What? Between
me and my dad, you turn up, you go in,
they give you your hair in there,
they give you medically pure heroin.
You can't take it out with you.
You've got to use it there partly because
they don't want you to sell it on.
But mainly because they want to monitor
you to make sure you know you don't
overdose.
Um,
you use it there and then you leave to
go to your job because you're given a
load to support,
to get housing work and therapy to figure
out why you can't bear to be present
in your life. Right? So it's
really important. They give
two things. There's puts,
bear in mind these two things because
the opposite of what we're doing at the
moment here,
give them the safest possible version of
the drug and give them massive amounts
of help to deal with the reasons
why they need that drug. You,
they're giving them a drug,
are they injecting it in
them? Yeah, they know they,
the individual injects himself or herself.
So if you, if you were the patient,
I'm the nurse, I give you the heroin
and I give you a clean syringe.
And one of the things
that really surprise me,
I at first I found really weird is they
will give you any dose of heroin that
you want apart from
one that will kill you.
And there is never any
pressure to cut back. And yeah,
I went there when it was 13 years after
this at first started and there was
almost nobody on the program.
Um,
from the start there were like three
people who've been there the whole time.
Almost everyone does cut
back and stop over time.
And I remember saying to a Rita, Maggie,
who's the chief psychiatrist there, well,
how can that be? Cause we're told
the chemical hooks take you over.
You need more and more.
If you had an unlimited supply,
you would just carry on forever.
What, how could, how could,
how do you explain this? And she looked
at me like I was dumb and she said,
well, we help them in their lives get
better. And as your life gets better,
you don't want to be anesthetized so much,
which ones that's explained to
you is so obvious. Right? But,
and it's worth just explaining the results
of the Swiss program in the Phillies
15 years.
Now in the 15 years since this began,
according to the best scientific
evidence be like Professor Ambrose,
Austin Haagen have shown
that had been zero deaths,
overdose deaths on legal heroin,
not one person.
There's been a massive fall in overdose
deaths outside the legal program cause
people transfer in because why would you
carry on using expensive shitty street
drugs when you could be getting, you know,
help and given the drug for free. Um,
and once it was fascinating about this
is Swiss people are really conservative,
right? My Swiss relatives make
Donald Trump look like Oprah.
And yet Swiss people after this had
been in practice for five years,
had a referendum on
whether to get rid of it.
And 70% of Swiss people
voted to keep her in legal.
Not Cause they're so compassionate.
To be honest. That's not, they're not,
they're really not a, it was
cause crime fell so much. Right?
It's much cheaper to give some crime fall.
I've got the statistics in the book.
It's fear since I wrote it,
but there was,
I think something like a 50%
fall in street street, crime,
street prostitution literally ended,
right?
There was no street prostitution
after that. Turns out women, you know,
don't want to be on the street being
fucked by random strangers, but about a,
if they've got like an
alternative, who knew? But the, um,
so it was an enormous fallen
crime across the board.
And the police confirmed that.
Everyone agrees with that in Switzerland
and all the kind of anarchy in the
streets just, just stopped. Right. But,
but what the reason I think is really
relevant to the opioid crisis is what
we're doing is the exact opposite,
right?
So they give them the
safe version of the drug,
give them help to figure out why.
Practical support to change
their environment to get
out of the isolet occasion
into a life that's more like rat park.
What do we do if you're
a doctor in this country,
finds out that you are
using say Percocet or Oxy,
not because you've got back pain,
but because you've got an addiction.
Your doctor by law has to cut
you off, right? They don't.
They can be busted as a dealer.
It's happened to lots of doctors
and so they have to cut you off.
So instead of giving you the drug,
we stopped you getting the drug.
Most people then,
or not most,
a very large number then transfer to
much more dangerous street drugs like
heroin. Secondly, far from giving
you how to turn your life around.
We give you a criminal record.
We shame you, we stigmatize you.
We put barriers between
you and reconnecting.
The opposite of addiction is connection.
But what do we do?
We put barriers between
people and reconnecting.
This is why that's one part of it, right?
So there's the drug policy part of it,
uh,
where we're doing exactly the opposite
of the country that succeeded in ending
it's opiod epidemic. But
there's something, I think
there's even deeper than that,
which you really see in places
like West Virginia, Monadnock,
the kind of hearts of the opioid crisis,
which is we're also creating a society
that's becoming harder and harder for
people to be present in, especially
in those, in those places.
There's an analogy I keep thinking of
in the, in the 18th century in Britain,
loads of people were driven out of the
countryside into these disgusting urban
slums in like a London and Manchester
and something happened that has been well
documented. There was sun called the
gin craze, right? Where basically shit,
loads of people just became alcoholics
drank again until they died. Right?
There's a famous painting from the time
called Gin Lane of a mother down in like
a bottle of vodka while a baby
like falls out the window. Right.
And things like that
really were happening.
If you look at what
people said at the time,
very similar to what they're saying now,
they said, look at this evil drug gin.
Look what it's fucking done to us.
If only we could get rid of this evil drug
gin, this problem would go away. Right?
We know now when we look
back at the gin craze,
it can have been Jenn that caused it
because anyone in Britain who's over the
age of 18 can go and buy gin.
Right?
And while we still have some alcoholics
to be sure we don't have massive
epidemics of our college and we don't
have babies falling out of windows,
what changed wasn't the
amount of availability.
It wasn't the availability of the drug.
The drug is more available
now than it was then.
What changed was the amount of pain
and distress in the society, right?
We don't have a study we've brought
as profoundly disorientated.
I mean it's going up because we're
creating more disorientation.
So if you create a society where peoples
basic psychological needs are not met
right, where they have shrinking number
of friends and social connections,
where they're taught that life is about
money and buying shit and displaying it
on Instagram,
excuse me,
where they spend most of their time
at jobs, they find unfulfilling,
controlling and humiliating. You can, uh,
create growing pools of people
who can't. And you, by the way,
that if you're constantly insecure,
financially insecure,
half of all Americans through
no fault of their own,
have been able to set aside $500
for if an emergency comes along,
she credits pervasive
insecurity in the society.
You're going to create very large numbers
of people who are going to want to
fill a need to anesthetize themselves.
Now, that's not a good solution.
Obviously I don't think heroin opioids,
these are not good solutions
to these problems, but,
but it's not a crazy solution either.
There's a line I think of all the time.
I don't quite hit very often cause people
can really react against this insight.
But I think it's actually important.
You know Marianne Faithfull,
the great like sixties British singer.
She went out with Mick Jagger. Annoyingly,
that's why people remember. She's much
better than Mick Jagger. In her memoir,
she shot heroin addiction in 60
she was homeless for a while.
She has this very challenging
line that I think about a lot.
I'm going to phrase it slightly
wrong, but she said, um,
heroin saved my life because
if it wasn't the heroin,
I would have killed myself at that point.
Right now Marianne Faithfull,
if not saying heroin was a
good solution to homelessness,
but we'd got to understand this drug
use is happening because it performs a
function,
right?
One of the most important things I'll
done for both of my books for chasing
scream and lost connection is that
these forms of despair, depression,
anxiety, addiction, they are
meaningful signals, right?
They are telling us something.
The fact that they had been
rising year after year after year,
that we're now at the point where average
white male life expectancy has fallen
in this country for the first time in
the entire piece time history of the
United States. That is a signal
that is telling us something.
And that's because of drug addiction
and overwhelming cause of drug addiction
and suicide is,
it's risen to that point.
Are there other factors
going on like obesity,
but that the main drivers are
a overdose and suicide and pat,
he's telling us something of what we've
been doing up to now is we've been
insulting that signal.
We've either been saying depressed people,
addicted people are just weak
or we've been saying, oh,
it's just a problem in their brain that
there are real things going on in their
brains of course. Um, or we've been
saying, you know, it's just craziness.
But in fact it is largely a
response to the way we're living in.
Of course there are other things going
on as well and we can talk about them.
And once you understand that, you realize
there's gotta be a deeper response.
And I went to places that had done
it, not just Switzerland, Switzerland.
What is the overall population?
Five and a half million.
So it's a small comparatively
small country. Yeah.
How much money do they have to
spend to keep this program going?
And what is the time constraints
in terms of like how long has a,
a person who's got an addiction
problem allowed to stay there and,
and receive treatment?
There's no time constraint.
You can stay on your
entire life if you want to.
In practice that doesn't happen very,
they stay in the facility. No, no.
They live in apartments
and they just visit.
They just go every day or
whenever they want to. I mean,
I think you can go twice a day and it's
free. It's free. It doesn't cost anything.
I mean, some people, once they have jobs,
then pay health insurance and
the health insurance pays for it.
But if you don't have money
than they pay for it. Um,
and one things that was fascinating as
they found it, it wasn't, and Joanne set,
uh,
did good research on or sites could
research on this for she to researched the
open society foundation.
It's actually cheaper than the
police constantly harassing people,
putting them in prison,
putting them on trial.
Those are really expensive things to do.
Heroin is unbelievably cheap
if you buy it legally. Right.
Why would they do the amount of money
they would save just in street crime being
radically reduced. Exactly. It makes it,
makes the life of the person
with addiction better.
It makes the lives of ordinary of other
citizens who would not addictive better.
Um, and it saves money. Right. Which
is why Swiss people are very pragmatic.
They're not, you know, the
most compassionate people,
but they are very pragmatic people.
That's why it was so popular system.
Let's think about another place that
adopted really different drug policies.
Right? Um, cause I think it's something
we can learn from there as well.
So Portugal around the time Switzerland's
having it's horrific heroin crisis,
Portugal is having a fucking
nightmare. Right? By the year, 2000,
1% of the population was addicted to
heroin, which is incredible. Right?
And every year they would like Swiss,
then they were trying the American way,
shame, punishment, stigma and things just
kept getting worse and worse and worse.
And then one day the prime minister
and the leader of the opposition got
together. And the louder, we can't go
on like this. What are we going to,
what are we going to do? And they
decided to do something really radical,
something no one had done since the
drug war began in this country 70 years
before. They said, should
we like awesome scientists,
what the best thing to do would be.
So they set up a panel of scientists
and doctors led by an amazing man.
I got to know him, Portugal,
Dr. Wow. Pulau it could
totally extraordinary person.
Um, and uh, who'd run the first of
a drug treatment center in Portugal,
founded after the dictatorship. And they
said to them, you guys just go away,
look all the evidence and figure
out what the hell we can do.
So they go away for two years.
They, they learn about rat park,
they learned loads of things and
they come back and they say, okay,
solution is we want to decriminalize
all drugs from cannabis to crack.
But,
and this is the crucial next step.
Take all the money we currently spend
on fucking people up, arresting them,
shaming them,
imprisoning them,
and spend all that money instead
on turning their lives around.
And interestingly,
it's not really what we think of as drug
treatment here in the United States,
right? So they do some residential
rehab that has some value.
Main thing they did was a big program of
job creation for people with addiction
problems saying he used to be a mechanic,
they go to a garage and they said,
if you employ this guy for a year,
we'll pay half his wages again,
much cheaper than sending
him to prison. Right? Uh,
they set up a big program of small loans,
so people with addiction problems
could set up and run businesses.
The things that they thought
were important at the time.
People like this is crazy. They're just
going to spend it all on drugs. Lunacy.
Right? By the time I went
to Portugal, it was again,
a 13 years since is gone and the results
were in addiction was down by 50% over.
This is by the biggest from the
British journal of Criminology.
The best scientific study of this
overdose deaths were massively down.
HIV was massively down.
Every single indicator on problems related
to drug use had fallen like a cliff.
Right? It wasn't perfect. There's
still got problems of course,
but there was a massive improvement.
And one of the reasons you know it works
so well is that virtually no one in
Portugal wants to go.
But I went and interviewed a
great guy called Cryo for Guerra,
who at the time of the decriminalization
was the top drug cop in the whole
country.
And he said,
what I'm sure Lozier your listeners
are thinking right at the time,
which was like,
if we decriminalize all drugs,
we can have an explosion in drug use.
We can have lots of kids,
these interesting nightmare. We can't
do this. When I went to see him, uh,
the audios on the Tyson's screen
website, he said, uh, sang,
like everything I said would happen,
didn't happen,
and everything the other
side said would happen. Did.
And he talks about how he felt really
ashamed that it's been so many years prior
to the decriminalization screwing
people's lives up when it could have been
helping them turn their lives around.
And,
and this is something that I
saw all over the world, right?
The places that have drug
policies based on shame.
And stigma and the fantasy that
you can get rid of drug use,
which you can never do.
Um,
they have mass really
terrible and rising problems.
The places that have policies based on,
okay,
let's restore order to the market and
let's give love liberty to drug users and
love and compassion and practical help
for people with addiction problems have
declining drug problems,
right? Again, not perfect,
but it was such a significant improvement
that support in Portugal. I mean,
they've got five main political parties
and none of them want to go back, right?
That tells you something, right? Yeah.
Now when they did this in Switzerland,
what was the primary cause for this drug
addiction and how did they deal with
that? So if they dealt with it in
Portugal with these loans and, and, and,
and helping our businesses by paying
for half the salary and all those things
like that seemed like wonderful ideas.
What do they do in Switzerland to
sort of mitigate what are the issues,
whatever the issues were that were
causing people to be drug addicts in the
first place. So it's a combination.
They gave people lots of therapy.
So I remember one of the people I spent
some time within that clinic had been,
um,
terribly sexually abused as a lot of
evidence that giving survivors of sexual
abuse safe places in which they can
release their shame about that leads to a
big fall in depression,
addiction and other problems.
It's a lot of evidence that
that, that kind of abuse is, is,
is a big driver of a lot of addiction
for a lot of people that clearly not
everyone. Um, some of it was just,
there were people who had never been
given a chance in life or I had never had
stable lives. Uh, it was
kind of a mixture of things.
And one of the things that's really good
about this system is it wasn't saying
in this kind of cookie cutter way,
the up and half often happens in drug
treatment in the United States are there,
there's plenty of good examples as well.
You know, you don't arrive and they say,
this is your problem.
We're here to tell you your problem
and how to solve your problem.
It's very much guided by actually
the person themselves, right?
People who are in deep pain. The, the,
the core of it is you have
to listen to them, right?
If we think about this addiction,
depression in the way that I'm arguing,
that we should see them as signals
that are telling us something,
most important thing is to listen to
the signal, right? I remember saying,
I thought about a lot,
this weird experience that I
kept thinking about all the time.
I was writing my book,
lost connections about depression.
And I started quite late,
late in the day that I realized why
I kept thinking about it so much.
I was in Vietnam about five years
ago now, maybe a little bit less. Um,
and I did this really
stupid thing. I was, uh,
I was in Hanoi and I was really tired.
I was do research for different book
that haven't finished yet. And uh,
by the side of the road,
I saw this big red apple or women
selling it and I'm shit haggling.
So I paid like $5 for this
apple or something out and
I took it back to my hotel.
I was so tired. I lay on the bed and I
start eating it and it was just gross.
Right? There were some
really, it's chemical taste.
It was like how I imagined a food would
taste after a nuclear war when I used to
watch these films in the 80s
right. Um, but I was so tired,
even though I knew it was wrong,
I ate like half of it and threw it in
the garbage and next like four days I was
just like violently sick right there.
Like just in like something
from the exorcist.
It's online there in front of CNN and
occasionally projectile vomiting and it
gets like bought it.
I'd had food poisoning before.
I basically lived on fried chicken in my
twenties so I was not new to this Rodeo
and after about four days,
I said to Hawaiian, my,
a fixer and translator who was a ranger.
I was there to interview survivors of
the war, the Vietnam War for something.
I'm like, look, I'm only here for
another three days, or whatever it was.
I've got to go and meet these people.
Otherwise this whole trip would
have been a waste of time.
So he drives me like six or seven hours
into the countryside and we get there
and he's lined up these people for me to
interview and I'm like, oh, thank God,
I don't feel so bad. Actually I
was sitting in this hot word, this,
this woman who's an 86 year old woman
who was the only person from her village
that survived the Vietnam War.
So I'm talking to her and now she's
speaking that the room starts to,
I've never had this feeling before,
and I've had a thing when you were drunk,
when you fill the rooms,
move it.
It literally felt like the room
was moving around me, like,
like I didn't feel like
I was disorientated. And
then while she's talking,
I just like explode all over
her heart from both ads,
like fucking horror show. Right?
And so I say to her, I'm just,
just take me back, put me in the
car, take me back to Hanoi. Right?
And he's this old woman's like sang, sang
to him and I'm just like, line there.
And he says, she says, you've got to go
to the hospital. We were really sick.
And I'm like, no, no, I just need to go
back to the hotel. And he said, Yo man,
this is the only woman who survived
the Vietnam War in this village.
I'm going to listen to her health advice
over yours. We're going to the hospital.
So we go to this hospital were,
I'm pretty sure I was there in the
European and I've been treated,
they take me in and cranks
like completely lying,
going like this is an
important western eye.
It will disgrace Vietnam if he dies there.
Right.
And so I'm lying there and they're like
jabbing me with everything and I'm like,
what's going on?
And they're asking me lots of questions
and I felt the most nauseas I've ever
felt right. And I kept saying to them,
give me something for the nausea,
three quant, because they didn't speak
English. And the doctor said to me,
you need your nausea. It will tell
us what's wrong with you right now.
Even line there were thinking,
it was kind of interesting.
I was where we think
of there and thinking,
they figured out it was the apple and I'm
having such a ridiculous thought where
I thought, I come about to die,
right? I've been killed by an apple.
I'm like eve or like snow white or
like Alan Turing. And then I was like,
you're about to die in your last thought
is that you're basically pretentious
con [inaudible] that horrified by myself.
Anyway,
they gave me this treatment and
a few days later when I leave,
I'm talking to the doctor and
just discussing various things with him.
And I said to him, what would
have happened if I'd, um,
if I had gone back to Hanoi,
if it shouldn't be about
10 away. And he said, oh,
well what happened is my kidneys has
stopped working because I hadn't kept any
water in for four days.
So it was like I had been in the desert
for four days and the doctor said, Oh,
you would have died on the
journey when it made it.
And so can think about this experience,
which really didn't actually affect
my life. Well, viewer and a thing.
It's the closest I've ever had
to a near death experience.
But all through research in my book
about depression, lost connections,
I kept thinking about this thing,
right? You need your nausea,
it will tell us what's wrong with you.
And I realized all the time I had been
depressed for think about my relatives
and people I love who'd
had addiction problems.
I had seen that my depression,
their addiction as a bit like that.
Nausea, right? As like a
kind of malfunction, right?
It's saying that you should get rid of.
And actually what we need
to do is hear it right?
Cause it will tell us
what's wrong with us. Right?
It doesn't mean it's a good
feeling. It's awful. Right?
Depression is worse than I've ever felt.
Uh,
addiction is a terrible state to be in.
It's not saying just in some kind of way,
oh we need to put up with it.
It's that if we hear the signal,
we can begin to find solutions
and all the places I went,
the places that have solved depression
crisis that I went to Veloce connections,
places that have solved addiction crises,
that w that I went to for
chasing the screen are places
that have said, actually,
this means something, right?
Your pain makes sense.
You feel these ways for reasons,
and we need to get down into these,
these deeper reasons,
which is really not what we've done in
the United States is the drug war began,
you know, uh, a century ago.